[music]
Hey there. Welcome to our hands-on
tutorial. Today, we're going to guide
you through setting up both horizontal
and vertical scrolling in a mobile
design. First, let's jump into our Figma
file where the mobile design lives.
We'll tackle the horizontal scroll
feature for our quick recipe filters
first.
[music]
We've used auto layout for each filter
item to keep everything organized and
well aligned. [music]
Here's how you do it. Select all filter
items and create an auto layout. You
might be tempted to use a regular frame,
but auto layout is a more efficient
option. We then establish a horizontal
space of 20 pixels between items. Next,
[music] we're going to dive into the
crucial part of creating this horizontal
scroll. Hold down the command key and
then [music] left click on the container
and drag it until it fits within the
dimensions of our phone frame. In
simpler terms, we're adjusting the
container to only show the content that
fits within the phone [music] screen.
Don't worry, all your content is still
there. We've just resized the container.
[music]
The following step is to activate the
clip content feature. This ensures that
content doesn't spill [music] out of our
phone frame.
After that, it's essential to navigate
to the prototype section. Here, we're
keeping the position the same [music]
but changing the overflow to horizontal
scroll. Now, we can test our work by
previewing our prototype.
As you can see, our horizontal scroll
function is working like a charm. If
you're interested in enhancing this
further, there are additional [music]
tweaks you can make for a smoother
experience, but we'll save that for
another session. Moving on, we're now
going [music] to set up scrollable
recipes while keeping everything else in
place. We'll do this [music] by resizing
our frame to match the dimensions of our
prototype. For this tutorial, we're
using the iPhone [music] mini, which is
375 by 812 pixels. Let's temporarily
remove the bottom navigation. Now,
adjust the height to 812 pixels.
Great. We can now bring back the
navigation and align it to the bottom of
the frame.
But, as we shrunk our frame,
[music]
our content now overflows beyond the
main frame. Select all recipe boxes,
create an auto layout, and then choose
clip content.
[music]
We'll also apply clip content to the
phone frame to prevent content from
spilling out of our main frame.
With everything now clipped, let's
preview our prototype. You might notice
that the content isn't yet scrollable.
That's because we need to take a few
more steps to get it to scroll as
desired. In a similar fashion to our
setup for the horizontal scroll, we'll
crop our content area and align it with
the bottom of our phone frame. Hold down
the command key, left click and drag
with your mouse until the container is
perfectly aligned. Now, we'll head back
to the prototype section.
We'll leave the position as is and
change the overflow to vertical.
Let's preview our prototype once more to
see the outcome. Awesome. Our vertical
scroll is now working flawlessly. And
there you have it. That's how you easily
create simple horizontal and vertical
scrolls in Figma. If you found this
tutorial helpful and are eager to learn
more, remember to hit the subscribe
button to stay updated our future
content. But, why stop here? If you're
serious about leveling up your skills
and taking your designs to new heights,
we highly recommend checking out our
UXUI Design Mastery course. This
comprehensive course is designed to
equip you with the tools, techniques,
and industry insights you need to create
stunning and user-friendly designs that
stand out in today's competitive digital
landscape.
I'm
only one away
from you
baby.